Assassin's Creed Mirage has a whole host
of interesting historical characters
from the setting where it takes place
which is 9th century bdad one such
prominent figure that is featured in the
game is the philosopher Theologian and
general polymath El
Jah in the game he's responsible for
overseeing the books in the house of
wisdom but in real life he's a much more
significant person than
that
or is indeed one of the most famous and
fascinating thinkers of his age and
perhaps in the history of the Islamic
world he was from Basra a city in Iraq
and stemmed at least partly from an Arab
tribe although he might have also had a
black African background on one side of
his family we don't know much about his
early life but he clearly received a
proper education as he was a master of
the Arabic language and would go on to
produce some of the greatest works of
Arabic pros of his day as well as being
an impressive and highly skilled
philosophical thinker around the year
8816 he moved to the city of Baghdad the
capital of the Abbasid caliphate during
the often called Golden Age of Islam
where he would essentially remain for
most of his life as he cemented himself
as one of the most influential
intellectuals in the world El Jah
devoured any kind of book and knowledge
he could get his hands on and was
interested in basic basically any kind
of intellectual topic and subject that
you can possibly imagine gaining a very
high level of proficiency in many
different fields for this he caught the
attention of the abased cffs themselves
who would often sponsor his intellectual
activities as part of the wider program
of intellectual development that was
centered in the famous Bal hikma or
House of Wisdom in Bagdad over the
course of his career elj has produced
some very famous and influential works
from the kab hawan or book of animals
which was essentially a book of zoology
which cataloged and recounted stories
and anecdotes about various species of
animals and their behavior or the
popular kab Al Bala the book of misers a
satirical book about greed and greedy
people that is often considered one of
the greatest examples of Arabic pros
from this early period those are
probably the most famous of his books
but he wrote many other works on many
topics and was involved in various
fields and debates from politics to
theology he was a proponent of the
Islamic theological school called the
Mah who put a major emphasis on reason
and rationalism for interpreting the
Quran and the Islamic religion and who
were at this time also officially
supported by the Abbasid cffs themselves
at least until the reign of Al mut and
in some of his Works he argued for the
muaz position against its critics such
as the so-called traditionalists and
Hadith Scholars that were growing
increasingly more popular at that time
and whom he often refers to with
derogatory terms such as the hash which
means something like useless or farsal
Scholars who were also often associated
with things like anthropomorphism and
although this School of Theology
eventually fizzled out for the most part
in the Sunni Muslim world alah has
remained one of the most beloved and
famous thinkers and writers in the
Arabic language even to this very day he
has come to represent the amazing
intellectual environment that was the
Abid caliphate during the so-called
golden age when institutions such as the
House of Wisdom gathered Knowledge from
around the world and developed new
philosophical and scientific ideas and
this very much plays out in Assassin's
Creed Mirage too as Al jahz in the game
works in the House of Wisdom as the
overseer of books his own writings are
still read and are of interest to
scientists today especially the
aforementioned kitab hawan or book of
animals which some consider to include a
clear precursor to the darwinian idea of
evolution and natural selection
indeed in the book Al jahz writes that
quote animals engage in a struggle for
existing and for resources to avoid
being eaten and to breed environmental
factors influence organisms to develop
new characteristics to ensure survival
thus transforming them into new species
animals that survive to breed can pass
on their successful characteristics to
their offspring which is the basic idea
behind evolutionary theory did this 9th
century Muslim philosopher figure out
Evolution not really but it is really
interesting to consider that some of the
basics of this important Theory had been
thought about and considered even back
then in more ways than one and more ways
than we have been able to mention here
Al jahz is one of the most interesting
figures from the early days of Islam and
probably in world history his role as
the overseer of books in the game is
fitting since he is said to have been
basically obsessed with books and
learning a popular story even tells that
after he moved back to Bas at the end of
his life he died after being crushed
when a bookshelf in his Library fell on
top of him being crushed by the weight
of his own books a poetic end to a great
man of learning and again the fact that
Assassin's Creed Mirage includes this
amazing figure is really exciting for
nerds like me and it's an important step
in allowing more people worldwide to
discover the amazing intellectual
environment of the Medieval islamicate
World
[Music]